I like literally my pew which I think
you should keep him
hey what's going on everybody for first
we feast I'm Sean Evans and you're
watching hot ones it's the show with hot
questions even hotter wings and today
I'm joined by the patron saint of hot
ones Alexa Chung camera one camera two
you know where is one of the fashion
world's power players from her books TV
shows and self named clothing line but
how does she handle her scorching hot
chicken wings we'll find out today Alexa
welcome to the show thank you thanks for
having me before we start if it'll allow
me to gush for a second sure without
Alexa Chung there would be no happens
what yes so our creator a producer
Christian burger over there I know it's
a big day for him he's wearing his nice
shirt oh that's great I'm wearing my
casual smoked dress from the 1800s he
was a big fan of your offbeat pop world
interviews and even the name hot ones is
kind of inspired by the big ones and
then you've been a white whale of ours
since we started the show it took us two
years to get you in the seat and at the
risk of just emptying a full clip into
my foot before the interview even starts
have you ever heard of this thing I have
via Bianca who's my publicist
if that sounds wanky I apologize
sometimes just go to have them and she
said there was this thing going on and
it was really cool and funny and loosely
based on this situation that I used to
do on television Britain just as we did
with your countryman Russell Brand and
Ricky Gervais we're doing vegan nuggets
today yeah Alexa you ready get going I
am let's do this
[Music]
hang on wait have you got your little
napkin there I suppose we can't do that
cousin Mike so I'll put it here
fine chill you're fine so I want to
start by taking it back to channel 4
naturally with pop roll because that
show much like this show seemed to be
designed to knock them out of their
celebrity media training yes you know
when that's the conceit it can either go
really good you can either catch that
yak or it can go flying off the rail
descent yeah we played a game could
scraping the barrel with Amy Winehouse
r.i.p who is obviously a legendary icon
and I absolutely loved her at the time
and loved her still but I suppose we
were probably complicit in part of her
downfall which was to mock someone
that's like on their ass essentially so
I really regret playing scraping if I we
were like what would she do to do this
we'll get a describe a barrel and she
literally like had a pint of whiskey
behind the thing but anyway she was
great sorry I shouldn't say she was
really funny I remember this really
witty like she's just on it a good one
would be what's his Navy sings and would
do anything meatloaf he was great I
asked him for some money and he gave me
some and then I actually kept him I was
like can you you're rich can you lend me
a tenor and he was like yeah and then
throughout the interview I asked for
another tenor and he just kept giving me
money and then he forgot to get it back
and I was like like flush at the pub
later like Melo gave me some cash those
are the days
[Music]
how far do people usually get I've seen
someone crying before Cara no sorry on
it yeah she cry uh yeah she had a hard
time but she made it through okay I mean
so you lived a pretty transatlantic
lifestyle since you moved to New York in
2009 yeah and the Alexa Chung effect
seems to be equally strong in London in
New York but not exactly the same so as
someone who has a foot in both worlds
what I want to do is settle some age-old
debates so I'll give you a category and
you can tell me which city reigns
supreme does that song yeah perfect
public transportation I mean they're
both bad on the New York subway is great
but then it you know you can wait on
platform for 12 minutes they don't
really tell you when one's coming along
in England at least you know where you
stand
it's like one minute away two seconds
away going to places that have funny
names such as [ __ ] Foster's where is the
better style Oh England sorry I think
there's a room for a reverence and
quirkiness in Britain or its expected
and celebrated when people are eccentric
this is going back from like you know
[ __ ] King George or something people
like it when you're a bit weird whereas
in America there's safety and uniformity
it's still interesting over here but
it's maybe a bit slicker whereas you get
fewer looks for dressing like a freak
when you're walking around in London
food America hands down or New York
specifically in England it's like
shepherd's pie and like really old timey
things they're all the same foods it's
just potato based beige stuff on a plate
where are the pret locations better Oh
London Britain Alison have you been to
English pret yes I have English press so
much far superior to American press but
what's up with the Dinan built in price
you know like when I'm a threat they
charge me more to en to eat it's a
privilege my friend well you want to
stand outside walking along with it
going down your chin now you want to say
to the table you're gonna have to you
know pay some more money for that but if
I go to Bret downstairs and I want to
eat in they don't bake in a cost but
maybe they're putting the cost somewhere
else maybe they're charging you for some
extra mayonnaise or something
so this next one is the secret aardvark
it's out of Portland you can tell
because that all works kind of better
like they've had a bit more wheat now
they're like you know be cool
you should have his nose like in the
bottle yeah man that's cool that's
crystal Louisiana all uptight we round
timey okay fine so as we've talked about
already you jumped the pond in 2009 to
host MTV's it's on with Alexa Chung yes
you know I could see it coming when they
said they were gonna call it that I was
like don't call it that because there's
an obvious pun that's gonna happen when
this is inevitably cancelled which it
subsequently was I got fired and then it
was it was off with Alexa Chung I was
like bye friends and everyone I love
family etc I'm going to America to make
it and then I got here had no friends
they'd literally not one friend they
rebuilt this Brooklyn apartment to
represent mine which didn't the same and
they wanted me to talk about what I was
doing every day but I was like what I'm
doing every day is receiving the script
at MB I'm learning it in bed getting up
at 6:00 coming back here and having a
nervy B and the other thing was I
refused to buy a television which was a
big bone of contention so I never really
knew who was all like there was they
would be interviewing like 16 and
pregnant people all like Bradley Cooper
before Bradley Cooper was Bradley Cooper
you know who is this guy and they were
like he's on a thing called The Hangover
and I'm like sounds terrible okay
Bradley you know so there was a lot of
that unsurprisingly they decided to
curtail the action
scotch bonnet mm-hmm have you ever [ __ ]
yourself just sitting here so far right
through me the other thing was on my MTV
show we have Bieber on as a recurring
guest because he wasn't like a big deal
yet no you had heavy hitters left and
right yeah Tyra Banks Kim Kardashian
yeah yeah I guess it was really like
well Bieber was on the verge of you know
tilting into being we since we used to
call him hog boy cuz whenever ASUS em
used to give me a side hug can we be
like a side kid
that's crazy and then years later I was
interviewing him on the Golden Globes
red carpet was doing that thing she went
terribly and he was being too cool for
me I was excuse me hug boy you're being
a little too cool for me we used to be
buddies in you know I'm sorry um yeah
that was funny I don't know what to tell
this does is this edited or is it just
wrong yeah yeah it's this is gonna cut
into nice little 22 minute episode B can
I tell the Golden Globe story to just
really clear it up once and for all
I think you should so hosted the Golden
Globes red carpet it was after my MTV
show was no more and I was just like
let's be business and my agent was like
we've got a job for you they want you to
host the Golden Globes red carpet and a
live red carpet situation is kind of
anyone's worst nightmare they'll be like
okay we've got Angele Angele Angele
Angele go all right hi hi sorry Angelina
and you just feel like a piece of [ __ ]
okay they don't want to talk to you
you're like you're literally like I'm a
piece of [ __ ] it's awful and then you
know in live TV you often have to fill
to make up the minutes
I hear them panicking about what they're
gonna do and they decide all right cast
and throw it to Alexa Alexa we're gonna
run down with some idiot boards which
are like the board with words written on
the like speak about the pink dress and
you're like yeah the pink dress so I'm
live I'm talking I see this flash card
it says speak about Olivia Wilde's dress
I'm like Olivia Wilde another person
really beautiful tonight there she was
in a gorgeous gown huge skirt so large
in fact you could probably smuggle three
humans in under that thing
I said humans they heard Cubans cut my
feed they're like over - over to Carson
I was like wait what and they're like
initially dee miking me no one really
said bye it was like a super weird they
let me do the salute goodbye to the
floating camera and then everyone sort
of like be just like backstitch and I
was like wait what if I said because
also had arrived there in like a
chauffeur-driven car and on the way back
my friend Tennessee pick me up in a
Volvo like literally she was like boop
boop get in I was like I don't know
what's happened it's really weirdos like
literally wearing like a weird [ __ ]
Chanel gown like well I'm filled with
and in the paper the next day they were
like who was that girl hosting that
thing firstly it was really weird
- she said you could smuggle Cubans into
the witch I didn't say and basically got
like blacklisted from any sort of live
hosting gig
[Music]
you may join source yes we did how much
does it retail for it retails for $12
we're at Heat nest
I love thank you for the thank you for
the tie-in I appreciate that I've
subsequently made a career out of doing
very subtle branding opportunities
alright so Alexa we have a recurring
segment on our show called explain that
Graham where we do a deep dive on our
guest Instagram poll interesting
pictures that need more context so what
I'll do is I'll bust out the laptop I'll
show you the picture and then you just
tell me the bigger story does that sound
good
yeah I was told about this and then I
was in the shower this morning and then
I thought of a really fun I've gotten it
now I was like you need to call it that
you had a better name for a second
hundred percent sorry what was it
alright laptop please it's a very slick
operation thank you all right first
things first
Larry David Larry David smooching
narrative I went to an Eagles gig in LA
to see the Eagles just I was there for
the refreshments and I was coming out
for the bathroom which is a very kerb
situation to find Larry David my friend
Remy and I were like let's ask Larry
David for photo I never do this part
from that cave the other day and he was
kind of grumpy about it but then in the
photo we started kissing him and then he
was happy turning the tables yeah yeah
so what's really weird about my life is
I'm either really famous or not at all
so if I go into Topshop for example it's
like [ __ ] Beatlemania but if I am
just anywhere else everyone's like who
and there's always this embarrassing
moment where a around 16 year-old girl
might recognize me I'm gonna oh my god
and then sometimes shake and cry and be
weird and the mum almost every time is
like who who is it who is it who are you
what do you do and then I'm like it's
really hard to explain
right I don't like that either would you
know like what do you do I'm like I
don't know why she's crying it could be
one of anything it could be that I once
met Harry Styles I don't really know
what she's freaking out about me
one more for you poppy and Cara sandwich
so Glastonbury is this magical land in
England when you find people in this
field which is when it's erected like
what a lot it's like towns in the UK
you're like gloriously happy to happen
upon anyone that you recognize it's not
like foaming at the mouth and like
wearing likes of tie-dye psychedelic
although character she really is wearing
a tie-dye see Franco her outsides are
matching her insides in that moment
I've known poppy since I was a teenager
I used to model together and Cara was
always her little sister and then she's
you know growing up to be Cara Delevigne
hot ones legend currently what's the
name huh yeah we're going for some dirty
dicks the second time today sorry I felt
like someone did me a favor and didn't
put as much on mine maybe I wouldn't put
it past Chris Mary he's beaming today so
near future fashion webseries provoke
delve into some of the aspects of
fashion that don't get talked about a
lot as someone who's been in the soup
since you were 16 years old what's one
thing that really is as bad in the
fashion world as everyone says it is and
then it's very creepy photographer is
being creepy yeah there's always just a
little bit of a weird transaction maybe
it can't not be cuz you're being
observed and captured for a purely
visual asset and then they're the ones
doing it's that power dynamic is always
gonna be weird because they like you're
beautiful it's just like the language
they talk like yeah that's good yeah
like that yeah I mean it just can't not
be wait it's just a little bit weird
[Music]
oh it just goes right in I mean that's
mean because you like loll else into a
full sense of security a them boom but
then what's the alternative Alexa would
you rather I start cranking it up early
no no oh my god it's like [ __ ] crazy
mm-hmm-hmm this is warring because this
is killing me and the next one's called
well unquote beyond insanity mmhmm yeah
oh so you wrote a weekly column for the
independent in 2008 and you believe I
used to write a [ __ ] weekly column on
my life and hosts a daily talk show and
as I enclose were made well then wrote a
great Kate Upton profile that describes
her and I quote epic breasts has been on
both sides of the coin as a subject and
as a writer made you more empathetic to
either side oh my god
it I casually my tongue can't form words
right right that's the show
that's the show I interviewed Emma Stone
for doink name-drop no it was my job
it wasn't like we're hanging out which
is that story so I interviewed her and
we went to this Museum of curiosity or
something in Brooklyn where you can like
dissect mice and learn about the Titanic
lots of different mysteries and and
[Music]
she's amazing and so I thought we were
like literally best buds by the end of
the day I was like ah mister my best
friend and then I saw her another time I
was like hi she was like hi but like
that thing not even an oscar-winning
actress can like fake knowing me I was
like [ __ ]
[Music]
oh I guess you ride the back yeah
I'm just using that as like a ball for
my child yeah yeah smart
so I know that you're all about the
music but you obviously have a
discerning eye when it comes to festival
style you once described the crowd at
Glastonbury as being a field full of
experts in layering and practicality so
what we've done is we've pulled some
crowd shots from some of the biggest
music festivals I'll show you the
picture and then I have a style question
for each image does that sound good
laptop please how you doing Alexa my
mouth satisfies prison it's so bad
alright first things first this is from
gathering of the Juggalos so if you're a
designer seeking inspiration what do you
get out of this crew ah I've seen that
workman tree would it go away ever it
has a half life Alexa it has a hum as
bad as you're feeling now is the worse
it's gonna be
well I've seen its documentary they all
dress like [ __ ] I'm getting nothing from
this Coachella now you're very generous
when it comes to other people's style
but as it's safe to say that Coachella
is the music festival with the highest
percentage of brick outfits okay listen
it's a well Coachella I don't know they
made it two weekends the emphasis on
commercial gain over artistry it tipped
and then got more people huh
I don't know what happened everyone
dresses like [ __ ] this is from Burning
Man what's your position on
accessorizing with Victorian era
antiques I called I had a seven-point
argument actually during the Burning Man
weekend when I was in LA every was like
you're going to Burning Man
I'd boiled it down I've now forgotten
the arguments cuz my tongue feels like
it literally disintegrates at uni do you
think I'll die like what's the worst
thing that can happen you will not die
you will not done well if I do I would
feel horrible about that and it would
take you know I don't think I could
continue the show so this one is Blair's
Megadeth sauce with liquid rage
[Laughter]
I'm at peak how about you see a little
bit
just a tip so you once said that DJing
for Lagerfeld is in fashion terms like
being asked to entertain God so when you
get booked to play say a Fendi party at
Fashion Week what's the process like for
preparing for the set
so I burnt all my CDs and I picked out a
playlist and I went on and then Kate
Moss came over and was like hi I'm Kate
Moss I was like hi nice to meet you and
she said arrange for someone else to
take really bad oh goody fine understood
it's that particular party you speak of
I lasted about 6 minute
all right Alexa you get to dispense your
own one of them so it's funny that you
say that this is the last daph we'd call
it the last dab because it's tradition
around here to put a little extra on the
last wing you don't have to if you don't
want to Alexa
how are you feeling is it worse than you
thought it would be so much worse you're
kind of like semi responsible for all
this you know I like lychee my people
which I think you should keep it
okay who's been the biggest [ __ ] dj
khaled by Miles huge a girl he tapped
after three DJ Khaled tapped our odd
vault so every season we'll just shuffle
in new hot sauces but the 3rd wing
equivalent hmm Wow Wow sauce whoa ha ha
ha
it was annoying me Freitas I was like
there's cookie for the bacon knows what
all right Cheers lexan Cheers oh they're
smaller special
[Music]
I likes a chunk now that you've gone
through ten vegan Nuggets run the board
back against the ropes but still
resilient enough to stay in your seat
and not projectile vomit I have one more
question for you and we're pulling a
page out of the Alexa Chung playbook I
want to take a wing to go down some
completely made-up fan questions which
in this case may or may not be recycled
from some of your own celebrity
interviews through the years does that
sound good great all right up first
would you rather have a receding
hairline or a proceeding hairline I
couldn't get over that one when we wrote
it proceeding cuz girl can have fringe
if you discovered you could bring the
dead back to life who out of Jesus and
vicious and Ronald Reagan would you have
a dry cappuccino with
my friend beavers write that my Cartman
behaviour today you don't even have to
answer it the beauties in the question
but Jesus Winona Ryder would you they're
really good
that was from this thing that's a really
funny radio show in England called just
a minute which is like super old-timey
it's what moms listen to i'm radio - I
think I'm actually gonna puke off this
and it's a pun game and they had it was
something like Oh one's got a horse one
one owner ride her don't worry about
that's where we go laughing I'm burping
up a storm
Great Expectations A Tale of Two Cities
in David Copperfield
do you enjoy a good Dickens I do love a
good Dickens well there you go you heard
it here first clearing the board getting
on top of me now Alexa Chung there's
nothing left to do but roll out the red
carpet for you my friend this camera
this camera or this camera let the
people know what you have going on in
your life this is the blood x that's
this alright
nothing much just I want something a
little bit asleep
but I have a fashion line it's called my
name the clothes are sick you should buy
them and yeah thanks hello world Sean
Evans coming at you to say thank you for
watching if you like what you saw please
subscribe
we're hovering around the 3000th rank
YouTube channel in the world it has been
a childhood dream of mine to be
somewhere in the mid twos we're so close
help make an adult bald man's dreams
come true please please please
jk jk no pressure but if you do
subscribe I appreciate it